Oh mine as it was mine to craft like
your your MA oh my gosh I'm a mother of
two children my niece plays it and I'm
also an elementary school teacher it's a
computer game and you might get to build
something you know that some of the
animals have I'm excited to see what
world I can create move forward I hate
moving it looks less realistic than
other video games that I've seen I like
the little steps doesn't look like a
hand it looks like a giant eraser am i
the watermelon no you're I'm holding a
zit shoot anything out of it oh I don't
know what the object is is it to advance
further yeah yeah it's really difficult
I think it's kind of artistic I can't
even get him to move this is a big tree
that's a big tree oh look daddy wood
right now I'm building a huge wall to
keep people out wait what the heck is no
my god what is that
this is long is that water it's kind of
dark no you're not hitting I guess I am
you know oh I fell in oh yeah
there's something reading a robot we
score zero I want to build actually a
little house like a bungalow maybe
spanish-style books
Oh Gold is a really hot fall color I
love Pinterest
I'm walling myself in a lot of work for
just a fear it's exciting at the same
time because I get to I just
didn't Lee crushed my house oh my gosh
oh my good man this is really intense
you know what that's a hard game that's
really hard
I like the artistic element it was a
little cubis kind of scary there was a
zombie I'm a spider
different than what I expected I had no
idea it had to do with bricks and
building and walls and creativity it
doesn't seem like there's an end so you
could play this for hours and hours and
hours and as a mom that would frustrate
me if my child
Charlie wait what is this costume Who am
I a keeper
[Music]